well the president is weighing in on the
topic that we were just talking about
here on the panel I don't know if the
TVs are on down there at mar-a-lago but
the he tweeted just moments ago James
Comey just through Andrew McCabe under
the bus inspector general's report on
mccabe is a disaster for both of them
getting a little lot of their own
medicine judge that IG report fully we
don't have an extent of all the things
that they have but we do know the mccabe
part and it is interesting that there is
a cross-section here of what co me
saying what lynch is saying what mccabe
is saying and and how this all factors
you know Jim Comey a graduate of the
University of Chicago Law School seems
to from gotten some very basic lessons
as Chuck just just pointed out we
believe he is a witness for Bob Muller
before one of the grand juries yet he is
really seriously damaging his
credibility by opining on everything
under the Sun having to do with this by
speaking on both sides of these issues
and the president is right that he threw
Andy McCabe under the bus yet he may be
a witness in a prosecution of Andy
McCain and McCabe's lawyers will for
sure play the interviews would you
question him next week when top
requested and him early today or
yesterday whenever it was and show that
to a jury is this man worthy of belief
look at what he said about this last
week yeah there are plenty of questions
by the way that will be left on the
table I think for our interview April
26th with James Comey here is the McCabe
team response to the criminal referral
today we were advised of the referral
within the past few weeks although we
believe the referral is unjustified the
standard for an IG referral is very low
we have already met with staff members
from the US Attorney's Office we are
confident that unless that there is
inappropriate pressure from high levels
of the administration the US Attorney's
Office will conclude that it should
decline to prosecute well how does that
go of what what Jim Jordan said in that
sound but I played earlier where the
most people say well way to say what
happened to Mike Flint right it doesn't
it doesn't matter what the political
pressure is here this is a legal
situation
about the fact that according to the
Inspector General Andrew McCabe lied
under oath to FBI investigators and
Inspector General investigators which is
a felony now the US Attorney her name is
Jessie Liu appointed and confirmed in
September of 2017 under President Trump
she's going to have to make a decision
with her attorneys in her office about
whether there is enough evidence to
prosecute Andrew McCabe but I find it so
interesting that his his indignant
attitude again towards the rule of law
in the statement that his attorney is
putting out when clearly there has been
a double standard especially when it
comes to Andrew McCabe being the one who
oversaw the Mike Flynn investigation who
allegedly lied and pled guilty to lying
to an agent not under oath quickly Rudy
Giuliani is telling reporters that he's
only gonna be on for a few weeks and
that he's gonna try to wrap up the
Muller investigation and kind of clean
up the loose ends and get Muller to wrap
this thing up he's got superpowers he's
the one person in the world who can wrap
up this investigation but if what that
means and you heard President Trump
allude to it a little bit in the press
conference he said we want to bring this
to an end
maybe there is honestly some new
thinking in the White House about the
best approach here that maybe if you
bring in Rudy Giuliani has a whole new
face to sit down with Muller and say
okay let's cut a deal of some kind here
well you know you can't rule it out but
it's a taller